in unseren insights dreht sich dieses
mal alles um die fashion week die zum
ersten mal trotz corona wieder mit
publikum stattfindet wir starten mit der
fashion week in mailand die letzte woche
stattgefunden hat model nicole marie das
berliner model dem erst kürzlich eine
beziehung mit brad pitt nachgesagt wurde
war aus dem laufsteg für boss zu sehen
später teilte sie fotos von ihrem
auftritt auf instagram und schrieb ich
träume noch immer von dieser perfekten
show auch die beiden place to be award
gewinnerin queen david und caro dauer
waren von bots eingeladen
die beiden teilten die highlights der
show in ihren posten und stories abends
waren sie dann gemeinsam beim essen des
modelabels und team sich super zu
verstehen wie wir während der fashion
week los ist zeigt fashion für unseren
leonie handel
sie nahm ihre community hinter die
kulissen mit und teilte ihren kompletten
tagesablauf von make up um 38 über
charity shooting um 15.30 bis zum dinner
um 20 30
bei der fernsehshow wahren stars sowohl
auf den laufsteg als auch im publikum zu
sehen
das model ashley grace präsentierte
einen der insgesamt 67 lux diesen teilte
sie zusammen mit ein paar backstage ein
drucken auf instagram der stargast der
schau war sängerin rita euro auf diesem
foto ist sie mit den designern silvia
venturini fendi und kim jones zu sehen
die fashion week in paris startet diese
woche die neue dior kollektion wurde in
einer physischen modenschau gezeigt und
live auf der website der band übertragen
viele stars verfolgten die show live aus
der ersten reihe und zwar von zu hause
auf ihrer couch dazu zählen die models
ann-kathrin götze carl levin und romy
street
[Musik]
[Applaus]